يمتلك شريف شركة مغربي للزراعة ، وهي
شركة تزرع الفواكه والخضروات في
جميع أنحاء مصر ، وأفضل سماد
للمزرعة هو أحذية أصحابها ، مما يعني أنه
كلما سار المالك
كلما كان ذلك أفضل ، وصحيح
أن
الحمضيات تشكل أكبر صادراتها في
مصر العام الماضي.  احتلت المرتبة الثانية في
العالم وأصدرت البرتقال ،
وأعتقد هذا العام أننا
[موسيقى]
يرسل شريف 50000 طن من البرتقال إلى
57 دولة حول العالم.
نيوزيلندا وجميع
البلدان الواقعة بينهما عندما أتيت إلى هنا ،
كانت هذه صحراء ، لم يكن هناك شيء هنا في
كل قطعة أرض حضرتها تصميم
نظام الري لقد اخترت
التنوع ما هو المحصول وهم مثل
الأطفال بالنسبة لي  أعرف كل شيء
عنهم ، يتطلب الأمر مساحة كبيرة
لتشغيل شركة بهذا الحجم
تمتلك شركة McRobbie للزراعة 15000 فدان من الأراضي في
جميع أنحاء مصر ، وتبلغ مساحة هذه المزرعة 32
كيلومترًا مربعًا.  هو في الواقع
حجم بيروت أكبر
هذه البرتقال هي نتيجة عام
من العمل الشاق
بمجرد انتهاء موسم الفائدة وشحن جميع
البرتقال ، سيبدأ شريف وفريقه
التخطيط للحصاد القادم
الذي استغرق مني 30 عامًا لبنائه في
مكانه  أنا سعيد جدًا بما
فعله فريقنا لأنه لم يكن
جهدًا فرديًا سنفعله مرة أخرى
[موسيقى]
آنا ستيوارت